joe biden's poll numbers as ari
mentioned are tanking and his vice
president's numbers are not that much
better many americans see kamala harris
as pretty phony incompetent not
particularly bright effective recently
she teamed up with a company called
sinking ship productions
perfect name to film what is a bizarre
cringe-worthy pr video and they had to
hire child actors and they all went all
in
with some analysis former arkansas
governor mike huckabee and fox news
contributor laura trump is with us
did we really need the child actors
and then all the extra peppy talk
why isn't she down at the border why
isn't she helping lower energy prices or
doing something other than this this
movie that she made
laura
well sean kamala harris is basically the
picture-perfect example as to why woke
virtue signaling does not work because
whenever you give someone a position
based on anything other than merit
anything other than what they actually
could bring to the table as part of your
team what you get is kamala harris
remember she wasn't chosen for any other
reason other than how she looks and they
were happy to tell us that during the
campaign i bet if you ask a hundred
people on the street right now anywhere
in america to name one thing that kamala
harris has actually done successfully as
vice president not a single person could
name one thing from failing at the
southern border being schooled by the
guatemalan president as to just how poor
a job she was doing there she didn't
bother to stand up for our closest
middle eastern ally israel when given
the chance and now we have this
ridiculous nasa video where as you
pointed out we paid a canadian company
sinking ship productions you couldn't
even make it up if you tried we paid
child actors because i guess no kids
could actually be recruited to try and
make her more likeable and this was all
in an effort sean to make her relatable
hey remember when afghanistan was
crumbling and people were saying where's
kamala harris we now know she was
shooting this video to make her a more
likable person so she couldn't be
bothered to do any job other than to
worry about herself and even that was an
epic failure
you know governor huckabee i don't know
about you i've now done radio 33 years
we just celebrated our 25th anniversary
i'm very honored to be here on the fox
news channel it's changed my life i'm
blessed beyond words
um i doubt you ever hired a
a makeover person
because two pr makeover people
apparently according to reports have
been hired by kamala harris then they
hired the child actors to do this movie
because i look at it as a movie while
ignoring all the real problems like
abandoning afghanistan and the economy
and energy
prices going through the roof um and
taiwan and china and everything in
between i think they'd be better served
to actually solve problems but what do i
know
well i want to tell you something if i
had hired some makeover people
they ought to get fired because they did
a lousy job with me that's something i
think most americans could agree on
wherever they are
actually no you were great at the
presidential debates
they might have a makeover on the beard
thing i think the jury's still out on
that part
you know well here's why i do think
thank you thank you laura uh the truth
is these kids all ought to get emmys or
oscars for their acting because they
really were performing brilliantly to
pretend that they were interested in
what kathleen kamala had to say
there's something that i think we need
to recognize about this whole ridiculous
video and the fact she's trying to come
out and be public she's been invisible
for most of her vice presidency the
truth is like joe biden they're both
better when they're in the basement it's
when they come out of the closet come
out of the basement come out of the
darkness when we see who they really are
and you know people say well she's just
got a lot of gas that's these aren't
gaffs sean
it's been said that a gaffe is when a
politician accidentally tells the truth
so when she goes out and makes some
blunder what she's really saying is
what's going on i really think that i'm
like a lot of americans who feel like
that with joe and kamala in the front
seat of the car
honestly i think i'm like a backseat
passenger in a car being driven by
thelma and louise right off the cliff
you know i think this might be the line
of the night laura you got to admit this
was good i think these the president
vice president are better off when
they're in the basement wow that's that
speaks volumes problem is these are real
problems and we've got a mess on our
hands laura trump thank you mike
huckabee thank you